[Music]
the biggest change in the 97 year
history of mist America the swimsuit
competition has officially gone up in
smoke and while some believe it's a
risky move while gretchen carlson Miss
America 1989 and new head of the
organization says it's about time so
candidates in the Miss America
Organization will no longer be judged on
their outward physical appearance
tonight's competition begins with
swimsuits which means the elimination of
the swimsuit competition and the evening
gown competition
hashtagging this historical move by by
the Keeney gretchen also tell dt miss
america will no longer be called a
pageant we're calling it the Miss
America competition and we're not
calling it a pageant anymore because
we're not having women in high heels and
swimsuits the new for Mary places swim
and evening wear with a live interactive
session between contestants and judges
aim to highlight achievements the 51
women will also have the opportunity to
wear evening attire candidates will have
a choice of what evening attire they
want to wear and they won't be judged on
that they'll be judged on what they say
when they're onstage
[Music]
the decision puts an end to a nearly 100
year tradition and ET has been asking
contestants for decades if it's times up
for swimwear would you like to do away
with the bathing suit competition I
think like most contestants yes I think
it's definitely definitely needs to be
downplayed but I do think judging
physical fitness is very important I
think the majority of us would like to
see something else instead of a swimsuit
competition because it tends people tend
to not take you seriously because of the
swimsuit competition
[Applause]
today we were with the reigning Miss
America Cara - she says her struttin
twirl and a two-piece last year hasn't
done a thing to help her in her actual
role of Miss America I haven't worn a
swimsuit since the day that I won the
title and so we're looking for the best
representative for who's gonna represent
this organization and you don't need to
wear some suits to do it now here's the
thing I'm standing next to a former Miss
South Carolina who won the bathing suit
competition so I need to know what do
you think of all this well that was a
long time ago I wouldn't win it today no
what do I think I'm glad that they're
taking it out because these women do a
lot of work for charity so they're about
so much more than their look yeah you do
a lot of charity work too oh I hear you
[Music]
[Applause]